really bad
and so you weren't on anything right
nothing i was completely sober i hear
the critics already that's right that's
right
it's fine i've had plenty of people that
i've told the story it's all the same
thing so what do you say to the critics
that would say this is just a dream um
there's a lot more to this world than
just physical there is a spiritual
battle happening right now there is a
great controversy truly happening right
now
so you're faced with two choices rap
battle or battle with the enemy which
one do you choose find out on this
episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome everyone to another episode of
led live we're excited to be here today
and it feels a little bit awkward for me
being in the driver's seat i haven't
done this for a long time i almost
forgot what to do and what to say but
happy to be here with these guys we have
a guest today
jose
and i'm going to tell you a little bit
about why jose is on the show and we'll
get to why he's here today
um
so i started taking
theology courses and i'm working on a
master's in theology so
part of that is i have to go back in
time a little bit and work on some
courses that i didn't have because i
wasn't a theology student
so i had to take greek one and two well
i'm in greek two this semester at the
time of this taping
and this guy over here jose is in my
class okay
and when i went to class
in the beginning there was kind of a
couple things that happened there was
probably three or four guys that stopped
me at one point were like hey man we
watched the show you know we're digging
it and i was like
not expecting that
um i'm a huge supporter of it yeah i
mean it's just it's just kind of odd i
don't ever expect to be noticed or
anything but
in public you you probably happen to you
and you you know you'll be out there and
people are like oh we got britney kind
of looking at you and staring at you and
like
like they know you from somewhere
i actually met one of you at the chinese
new year okay and yeah candy yeah candy
there you go okay and um i was like yeah
i know you and she was like yeah from
where from it was like from the show
yeah
she was like wow that's awesome you know
it's so cool to me to that we're
reaching your demographic like how are
you i'm 25. see man that's what i want
to reach like 18
even younger but that range man
i got introduced uh to the show
from from a friend of mine that goes uh
to church and chuckling first yeah so
after class one day
he starts up a conversation with me
about this about the show and i started
asking him some questions he starts
sharing some information and
and of course the guys that are in my
class by and large
they're
going to be pastors that's what they're
in school for that's why they're taking
greek one and two some of them are going
to go on to intermediate greek i don't
know if that's in your future yeah
that's definitely my future i don't
think it has to be in mine so i'm going
to be in the greek reverse for a while
okay
so we're we're
we're taking greek these guys are going
to be pastors and and i we're talking
about his past and a few of these key
words come up like music industry and
like
what was the other one like a cult and
i'm like okay there's a story here we
need to talk about this so
you are on your way essentially to being
a pastor
and we don't know where or
all that yet but
you weren't
you weren't always on that path you you
have a different past in fact you
weren't even baptized that long ago it
sounds like yeah so july 24th tell us
about
what it is that you used to be
into what it is that you so do well
i started rapping at a very young age
like 10 years old 10 10 years old i
started freestyling okay um you know my
brother he got me into it you know and i
just
i really just kind of fell in love with
it i enjoyed it a lot
um i'm out of curiosity we're different
uh generations what were some of your
influences as rappers oh some biggie
smalls
tupac oh
you know because my my brothers were all
old school you know so like i really um
was influenced by them i i liked i even
liked run dmc too you know and uh krs-1
and a lot of these old school rappers
like nas and then that later eventually
started to um kind of take an evolution
where i started listening to rappers
like j cole and kendrick and you know i
went through a bunch of phases of music
which i'm sure that a lot of you know
kids go through right
um
but primarily
rap always kind of like really stood out
to me i just kept writing writing poetry
and it was kind of a way for me to
express myself yeah and um so around
like 17 years old you know i really had
just
decided to go
full committed on to just pursuing rap
and then it became into like this
obsession where i was just like all i
wanted to do was rap you know so are you
done with high school at this point yeah
i'm already
getting towards the end of high school
okay towards the end and then you're
just you're gonna make this a career
yeah and that's what i that's
essentially what i did um i went down
the the rabbit hole really and just
continuing to pursue it for a while and
i had some experiences i had some kind
of like a kind of duo
partnership that i made with someone
where we were kind of just like wrapping
together and i had a studio in my
backyard and
i was doing competitions which you know
this this
performance in particular that we have
here on the screen um
is one where i performed in miami beach
and um
but that was like
years later on you know so it was kind
of just like a very long process of me
getting into the industry and um yeah
can you tell me about that because i i
for those of us that don't understand
how the music industry works really um
and all we can see is hollywood really
all we can see is the music industry in
the uh on the tv screen how do you make
money outside of being the the top of
the top like you go to different so
they're gonna be doing venues you're
gonna be doing venues short venues some
people there's there's only a certain
point that you can really reach
where um your span of influence is not
already being kind of
geared by someone else right so even
independent labels even independent
artists at some point or another they're
kind of conforming because i mean once
you get to this this money plateau um
people would start to notice okay you
have influence and you have power now
right so you could actually start to
change things
um
luckily
well not luckily by the grace of god i
never made it to a higher standpoint
where i was making enough money to to
really kind of make a fool on influence
but i was getting there yeah um you know
i started making connections with people
and um and that's the biggest part it's
all about who you know yeah it really is
about who you know but the the real
problem is the spirit behind the music
industry you know so yeah you'll be
making money at um doing little gigs
here and there you might make like 300
you know a night or something like that
and you know then the music that comes
from the streams so now you're streaming
you get like a hundred thousand views
you're making money from that too one
thing about being
that kind of a celebrity is you don't
have to pay for things you start getting
you go to the bar everybody wants to buy
your drinks everybody's trying to smoke
weed with you you come hang out with me
crash on my couch whatever like you can
literally be homeless almost and and not
be home
supporting you you know and and you kind
of become part of that
that team and that that lifestyle and
it's
it's it's very draining and from what
i've noticed
from my own personal experience even if
you're a low-level artist
you're you're conforming
you're conforming to that spirit you
know you're conforming to to the message
behind the rap
um movement yeah you know because it's
just one huge movement everybody has
their little waves in a huge giant
tsunami
so
did you grew up in a christian home i
did
grow up in a christian homes catholic
um
i wouldn't go as far as to say that we
were devout catholics where we were
going to church every sunday but my
parents did teach me some good morality
um there were some good morals instilled
um
did they see a problem with this
well not really
no they were just supportive yeah they
were supportive of whatever it is that i
wanted to do that was amazing you're not
a single child are you i am not a single
child okay i'm an only child so my
parents were really supportive of
everything i did and
yeah no matter what i did it seemed like
they were well not really so much when i
was like the gothic just blasphemous
stuff but when it was like the party and
stuff like that
they they're really supportive just
they just wanted to support me no matter
what i did yeah yeah it was always
something with with
we we believed in jesus you know and and
we believed in and doing right onto
others as well and i was always taught
that as kid now there were some things
they're kind of blurred along the lines
but i mean you know
that's a perfect tone you're 17 you
decide to embark on this career
as a rapper how long did that go on for
before
you come to a point or experience where
you realize you have to make a decision
okay so i mean
when where i really started to make my
decision was around
around 21 years old
where i had i had like i was i was
saying
um
i had really gotten into that spirit and
i started working at a boxing gym
and then that boxing gym i met someone
there who was who was connected and then
i started really getting into um into
meditation eastern meditation okay and
and so
when i really started to get involved in
the eastern meditation is when i really
started to feel like this spiritual kind
of torment you know where like i was
kind of doing things where i wouldn't
normally do i was having some type of
outside influence
and
i always really tell people be careful
with eastern meditation because it's
like you're emptying your mind you know
and so something else is going to fill
that biblical meditation is is actually
having the word of god fill your mind
and that's what's leading you right yeah
and so that's what really started to
happen to me and then i started
surrounding myself with those types of
people and uh to this day i do believe
that a lot of those people were
connected with the occult what about you
said you were raised with christian
values did you have
would you say that you were a christian
would you tell people your christian so
as a christian
when you started getting in the new age
or the
eastern mysticism and stuff did you feel
like that compromised anything or was it
just like you thought like relaxation
and stuff or were your belief systems
changing
they were changing because i had um
started to
be
introduced to the adventist movement
and i started learning about truth you
know about the sabbath and you know
about um other things like um
you know just some some of the core
doctrines that that is involved with
with our you know with adventism and
it's just it was really kind of like i
was in a standstill i was one foot in
the world and then one foot with
christianity
and my major breaking point is when i i
had um i had a spiritual experience this
happened to me twice where i was kind of
like in a sense led out
um into the wilderness
by uh by satan you know and i had my own
spiritual battle out there where i was
literally three days and three nights
without food and water
and i was just
i experienced a lot of torment and i
experienced satan um
face to face you know um this this
particular encounter it wasn't as direct
as my second encounter where it just
like pushed me over the top and i was
like look satan is real
and um there is a huge controversy at
work right now and
god he's called me to be a pastor and to
work for his kingdom because you know
satan is at work
yeah so what were those experiences yeah
so let's go into that a little bit more
because that's that's pretty intriguing
how old are you at that point i was
around 21 years old okay so 21 so 21 is
just it's just the pivotal moment and up
until then had you been like supporting
yourself doing this full-time yeah well
i was kind of in between jobs you know i
was doing security work but i was also i
was also making money too
um online with streams i was making
money on the side with that so i had um
i had a song that got around to like
seventy thousand sixty thousand uh plays
on spotify and i was really starting to
build some traction but um some
experiences happened to me later on
where um
really it was it was
kind of god opening my eyes to what what
was really going on in my life sure and
what i wasn't i wasn't doing what was
correct
so i just took it all off so this this
seems at some point it seems like
there's a struggle going on because
you're starting to be introduced to
eastern meditation
but then essentially like satan comes to
you
and he's tormenting you yeah which seems
odd because if you're in going down the
eastern meditation route it seems like
you just leave you want like yeah
there's no point bothering this guy i
mean he's going down the wrong path yeah
so what is it that happened either at
the same time or in between those things
i was pursuing christianity okay i was
why i was in the adventist church
because i was actively seeking truth
okay you know but i was also working at
a boxing gym and meditating what what
caused you to seek truth out i mean you
were just in that mindset of i just want
to seek truth or did somebody hand you a
piece of literature
actually
what really got me down um i had always
i went to a baptist school okay um when
i was when i was younger and that's
where i really had my first encounter
with jesus
i really
learned about the love of jesus there
i went to a public school later on and
kind of lost my way
um and then uh later on i got introduced
on to um to mark finley and his ministry
um
because i was i always liked to research
christianity and i was really into kind
of like the occult as well and kind of
what was going on in the music industry
and um just had also uh been looking for
truth just seeking i i knew that there
was something in my life that wasn't
right and i was going in the wrong path
but i just didn't know exactly what it
was because i was so obsessed with the
music industry and rap so you stumbled
onto him from doing a youtube search
on to him i promise wow that's crazy and
and then i saw something about the
sabbath sabbath what is that
so youtube ministries it works
it does what's kind of crazy about mark
finley is
you know for those that maybe don't know
he's
you know during when when the berlin
wall fell and then like the you know the
russia was kind of all in in turmoil and
all this kind of stuff
mark finley went in and did evangelistic
meetings like all during that time and
and he um
like he had a series of evangelistic
meetings at the kremlin
at the kremlin at the kremlin it was
like i mean when you heard about it was
like that's impossible like
it was only like god could do that you
know to open things up to where he could
do that so that's super cool you
definitely work through that ministry
with me because that's really what
started the whole entire train i even
decided to go to um to an adventist
church and start you know commuting with
them and and that's where kind of like
that that struggle really happened
where it was like god was trying to pull
me this way and then satan was trying to
pull me where are you living at that
time
um i was living with uh at my my house
with my mom yeah what what part of the
country or miami in miami yeah okay so
you're in miami and you stumble onto
mark finley how many videos did you
watch like
i had a few i was really interested okay
so interested that it took me to the
church
you know because i i never heard about
the the bible sabbath ever
and i had been
you know christian
right raised up with with jesus being
known in my house right it wasn't a
perfect home but it was known in my
house sure you know so um
it really
it really intrigued me that
i had
supposedly heard about you know
jesus and and certain truths but i had
never heard about the bible sabbath and
it's like man it's like it's the first
time and it's like why didn't i hear
about this yeah and uh
and so that really interested me and i
started even keeping the sabbath um
and and just kept doing that for a while
it was a really long journey for me i
mean are you still rapping you still
yeah i was still rapping i was making my
transition as a boxing trainer
while i was working at that boxing gym
and um but i was you know it's that
power struggle where i was actually even
started to change my diet along the way
too and i started to just go to church
more and and just be more spiritual but
i had that mix-in of the eastern
meditation in there as well and so i was
still rapping um i was actually during
that time really debating just letting
it go okay um but just satan really did
not want to let me go you know he just
wanted to continue to use me for did you
think well maybe i'll just change my
lyrics or yeah he didn't like that okay
or good messages yeah yeah have you
heard ivor meyer's testimony i think so
oh man you gotta watch it yeah escape
from the black hole you'll really
identify yeah i think i have some people
have told me about it but i haven't
gotten around to actually watch it i
need to yeah i definitely will check it
out so you start to go down this
new path yeah
then what when when does when do when do
you have this encounter where you're
like you have to make a decision on
which way so it was actually a couple
years later um because i had my i kind
of stepped away from the church you know
the music kind of dragged me back in and
i really just stepped away and then
later on um during covet
copy 19 hits and it's kind of just like
something sparked in my head
you know where it's just like
what am i doing right now
you know look at the signs of the times
right now we're we're in a huge like
lockdown and um there was this ministry
that really kind of woke me up it's
called a truth
um unedited
and i i may not agree with everything
per se but it i think it's a good
ministry that is putting out some good
bible truths
um
and it woke me up
it woke me up out of my slumber for real
and i just started to really just get
back into into the word i started um
watching uh youtube ministries again
there's bible flock box i don't know if
you guys have ever heard of him um he's
another ministry that really helped me
out so i shout out to you thank you
you're amazing um amazing prophecies
um with mark fox yeah i started really
watching uh mark fox and um
dustin too with uh so i forget the name
of social media now he's with what yeah
it was hope through prophecy yeah yeah
hope through prophecy um and those
channels and doug batchelor too amazing
facts i really started watching amazing
facts a lot um and it really just
started to kind of uh shape me and mold
me better but then
i ended up you know saying brought
something into my life again i ended up
going to the school for uh massage
therapy
and um their main philosophy there was
taoism oh yeah right i just heard this
today dude i'm telling you i talked to
this girl who's helping us a little bit
with marketing and stuff today
and she said that uh she went to school
for masseuse massage therapy stuff and
she said there's so much of that in
there like you can you almost can't
escape it yeah
and and and that's what happened i
started to kind of like mix and mingle
with the taoism and got back into that
and i could i could really say um
you know that that some of those people
they were connected too you know like
saying he he plants people in certain
areas you know he brings you into a
place where um you can be influenced and
uh taken to the path that he wants you
to go can you expound on that a little
bit what do you mean by um they were um
it was interconnected were they some of
them yeah yeah they were teaching
straight up taoism um taoism okay so
taoism for for those who may not know is
is the philosophy of uh they believe in
primordial unity where uh the beginning
of existence came from an eternal
nothingness
right and from that nothingness life was
created and it has to do a lot with um
the elements you know like water earth
metal fire
and it has
it's directly connected with the body
per se
um and they teach that in the massage
therapy itself so you go through a lot
of like uh the chakra points and cheek
points it's funny because your initial
description sounds so much like
evolution yeah nothingness it created
nothing nice and then we have
yeah it's it's very similar you know
and um i mean it's all got to stem from
somewhere sure
so
thread yeah it started there man it
started there and um
essentially i had really started to mix
in with that and i i to this day believe
that some of the some of the people
there were definitely practicing or
there were witches and there were
wiccans and stuff like that and um
that's
i started to mix in with that and and
mixing christianity with that again we
got christian witches now man yeah it's
getting really crazy they're out there
you know they're out there and um
that's really where i i stayed there for
six months and i can tell you that there
it was a huge
up and down for me um i really started
to see it affect because up until the
point that i went there my spiritual
life was prospering i was getting closer
to jesus i was even doing youtube uh i
had a youtube ministry okay yeah and i
was exposing bible truths and and and
just
um bringing people the truth you know
after you hit stop you go over there and
meditate
no even at that point i wasn't
meditating
right but then as soon as i got into
that that uh that school is when i
started to be exposed to that and you
know it just goes to show that god will
he'll bless
those fruits when you're fully following
him but when you're not fully following
him it's like okay i have to put a cut
to this because right now you could
start to bring people the wrong message
so you've been brought to another
another path
and now at some point you make a
decision so what was that decision point
i got to a point where i was so
tormented
from from the eastern meditation um that
i was
i basically got possessed
what do you mean tormented like i got
possessed i i had the spirit of um i had
i had demons at me man for real and i
went and did something um that i
normally would not do i wouldn't cause
discord within my own family
right and then from that point i ended
up going out to the wilderness again
into a place where it's like i'm
actually i'm going to write a book about
my experience because
this place
you cannot get to unless satan will
influence you to get to that place and
they call him the prince of the power of
the air for a reason right um
not to say that he has more power than
god because he most definitely does not
but there is some leeway
he uses his power in a manipulative way
where god and he's
he's hoping to draw you in and satan's
forcing his way and through every trick
in the book yeah and so when you say out
in the wilderness you mean like
literally
out in the wilderness i went to the
everglades okay and um
also the metaphor wow no it was really i
went out to the everglades and it's it's
crazy how how it happened because i'm
driving in my car
and i'm i'm in a place called opa-locka
right and i'm heading down the street
and then from one second to the other
um it's like my car was transported
to this location
and then i like you just kind of blacked
out no i saw it all happen i saw
everything start to move around me and
then from one second to another i was at
the place that i was going to go and
walk to now that sounds completely
insane but it happened to jesus he was
says satan took him to
the the top of a building or whatever
and said jonathan acts too not jesus but
there's another another disciple sorry
about philip philip yeah and you know
part of that actually happens and and uh
while while i'm out there you know
so i get taken out there
um and i start walking i take off my
shoes why would i take off my shoes you
know um it's this it's just the
symbology of the whole entire walk in
itself is is incredible because i go out
to this place where it's just a narrow
path nothing but a long narrow path it
just continues to go on to what would
seem like eternity
and uh i just start walking
i just start walking and walking and
walking and walking i just don't stop
walking and then during this time i'm
having visions
um you know of kind of like the world
being destroyed around me and then um
satan is telling me lies about how i
have to uh lay down and die right here
in order to get raptured and it's like
it's a whole entire experience that
really to go into the full depth of it i
need to write a book sure sure you know
but i will i will give the main uh core
points of exactly what happened
so i'm out there and i'm just walking
right and i get to this point where um
it's just it just seems like i'll never
make it to the end sure
and at that point jesus he tells me
himself he says this is where your life
is going if you keep on walking
the way that you're walking
and at that point i turned around
and um it was
it was the major turning point in the
decision i had to make
but it was far from over
so you turn around mm-hmm
and then what you got to like hike back
to you
back
yeah i'm um the thing is though it would
seem like i would get back there quicker
right but as i'm turning uh back the sun
starts falling down
and it seems like as soon as the sun
comes down from one second to another
it's like i am in another world
and the darkness comes and vultures
and um they were just theirs uh actually
previous i think this is an important
fact just to
point out the fact that satan he's he's
using certain mediums in order to
influence people um
the
womb out there
these birds appear and i know this is
gonna sound crazy
these birds appear and they start
telling me to go into the uh the swamp
that's next to me right and kill myself
and it's kind of like they were
torturing me in a sense where i would
get a little bit closer to the um
towards towards the lake area the swamp
area and as soon as i would get there
it's like they were taunting me oh
you're really gonna do it he's actually
gonna get in there he's really and then
i would step away and they'll be like
dude get out get in get out and it's
kind of like this very torturous
experiences like
really bad
and so you weren't on anything right
nothing i was completely sober i hear
the critics already that's yeah that's
right sure it's fine i've had plenty of
people that i've told the story they saw
the same thing when you're when you're
messing around with drugs you're
entering into satan's realm you're
opening up a door for satan to put i
mean people who do dmt and stuff they
they all have the same experience they
blast out of their body into outer space
they meet aliens or uh god and wow she
is amazing you know it's like this
female god thing
and
but then you don't have to do drugs new
age meditation stuff leads that way too
you start having interactions with
ascended masters and all these things
true and experiences visions and things
and and when you start looking into
those books those new age books like i
have some for uh research and stuff
like this thick and literally everything
is scripture
and it's like if you didn't study the
truth this would be so deceptive because
you're like that's it's about god it's
about creation it's about christ within
he's in me and i can become christ you
know we want to be more like christ yeah
it's very easy for those things to
to get blurred you know when you when
you don't have the fullness of the truth
and uh for for a very long time i was
struggling with that because that's what
happened to me you know i was seeking
for truth
um was something always it was the holy
spirit really that that led me to
to the truth because i was i was trying
to find it and it was it was a struggle
i completely derailed you i'm sorry i
can please continue with this so it
after that after that
short power struggle i kind of like
um
kneel down and ask god to to take me out
of this like because i'm in complete
torment you know i was in real deal
torment and um and you know he just
tells me you got to keep walking that's
the only way you're gonna get out of
here just keep
walking and it's the narrow path and
yeah it's literally i'm walking down the
narrow path
um and then it turns into nighttime and
you know these apparitions appear um as
they were impersonating family members
wow you know
and so you saw these things i saw the
dead family members they were living no
living family members
they were impersonating living family
members kind of to try to deceive me to
you know get rid of myself
and um
this part
uh i i get stuck do you guys are you
familiar with time loop do you know what
a time loop is i've been in one when i
smoked salvia yeah you're talking about
it's very similar to it it's like it was
like a i don't know five minute high but
i feel like i was never going to come
out of it yeah picture this
i'm
walking and alongside this narrow trail
there's these posts right and every time
i would get to the post it's over here i
would just end up right back at this
post
and that was happening to what would
seem like an eternity right and i'm not
on any drugs or anything like that this
is this is an actual experience that was
happening to me because satan did not
want me to leave with the knowledge that
i had learned about the occult you know
because i started getting into the
eastern meditation and while i was in
that school i started you know making
connections with people and learning
things that i probably shouldn't have
learned you know which i'm gonna detail
more in my book as well um
but it sounds like you gave him enough
access to torment you and try to get you
to kill yourself yes but god was
protecting you from him killing you yeah
so he that's why he's trying to convince
you to kill yourself yeah that's what it
was you know and so i get i that
happened for a while and then
when i entered into the trail to this
narrow narrow trail there was only one
way and one way out
the way that you came in was the only
way that you're gonna get out because
there was there's literally no other
beaten path or anything it's night time
and after i get
out of this time loop um i end up
getting to an exit
and it was a different location
than where i had entered from and there
was actual literal people waiting for me
at the end
and this was a good thing right this was
a bad thing bad thing there were people
from the occult oh okay and they were
people from the occult what yeah
satan is communicating with people in
the airways man he's he's he's literally
using just like how jesus has his
kingdom here he has his pastors he has
his ministers he has you know people who
are conference president or you know
just people who are owning
a ministry or
working for jesus satan has the same
exact thing you know and if people think
that he's not communicating with him
with his people uh in in those pathways
um then you know they're sorely mistaken
how do you know
i just say we've heard it a lot you know
grant morrison the comic writer said
that he was you know approached by a
being and he told him to do this and
then we see people who channel aliens
supposedly and people who have ascended
masters so yeah there's communication
from the demonic world to humans i'm
sure they were saying hey there's this
guy who's gonna expose you guys go out
there and meet him yeah
and and that's how did you know they
were from the cult did you know these
people before they started they started
talking to me
i was behind um i had i had
sex because at this point i'm i'm
already i'm feeling like
god had put the impression upon me
they're going to do something bad to you
really bad to you you only have two
options you know either join the occult
and go with them
and don't fight it don't struggle or run
away right now and i can save you and i
can actually take you to where i want to
take you you know and that's that's
really what what happened and what were
they saying to you they were they're
impersonating my family members in two
um and they were saying
um
don't
don't don't fight it just let it happen
we're going to do something to you right
now and what they were going to do to me
is they were going to sodomize me
they're going to they're going to
violate me because when you really start
learning about the occult and what's
going on in
in that world what they do to men is
they they they sodomize them and um
what they what they they sodomize women
too but they they start to the more vile
it is
the the uh the more control or power or
influence you're gonna have right when
you really start getting deep in there
yeah because the more the worst thing
you can do
makes the person feel that they can't
come back to god so they think they have
sold their soul so that's why it gets
worse and worse and worse and worse as
society gets worse and worse and worse
and worse because if you can make
someone do something bad like hey i'm
going to go steal a piece of bubble gum
well that could have been the worst
thing at that time period but now they
got to get to the point where
you are sodomizing someone to the point
where it's going to get and which i
think it is now even in hollywood we're
getting inklings back that pedophilia
yeah is the biggest thing where you
actually go and make these terribles
huge yeah
yeah and um that's that's what they were
going to do to me you know my experience
um is an extreme
not everyone has to go through this not
everyone should have to go through this
personally i was very hard-headed you
know god was pursuing me and he really
wanted me to he wanted to take me out of
that world but my obsession was kind of
something that he didn't force himself
upon you and he's so long suffering he
could have looked at you and said this
guy is a lost cause
but because he didn't i turned around
and so they told they were starting to
make that impression on me and uh jesus
told me you need to turn around and
leave and that's exactly what i did and
i walked i walked back from where i had
came and i sat down next to this post
and i could look and see those people
they were pursuing after me but they
couldn't see me
it was like i was invisible you know
and um then every time they would get
close to me it's like jesus would whisp
me away like he did with philip and the
ethiopian eunuch i ended up after that
falling asleep out there i went through
this uh um still satan didn't really
want to let me go but as soon as i had
woken up it was daytime and
it's kind of like i had been
i died and was you know resurrected so
what do you say to the critics that
would say this is just a dream um
i would say to the critics that they
have never truly
understood what the occult is and i
would recommend that don't ever take
that step to really go deep in because
once you get deep in
it can be harder for you to get out not
impossible because jesus will take you
you know where you need to get to um
but if you're mixing yourself in with
darkness you know
you got to clean yourself you kind of
got to purge yourself of that
jesus has to purge you of of those
things you know
and so what i would say to them is that
um
you're only looking at the physical
aspect of things
and
there's a lot more to this world than
just physical there is a spiritual
battle happening right now there is a
great controversy truly happening right
now there's a battle for each and every
single soul
and um
we're wrestling out against flesh and
blood yeah we wrestle not against flesh
and blood so that was
the first time
that that was that was my second that
was the second yeah okay that was the
second time and then after that
experience as soon as i had turned
around they took me to a hospital
um who took you so so no i i ended up
meeting there was ambulances waiting for
me there it in a sense yes i could say
as soon as i had woke up and it was
daytime and i walked back i got to the
same location i came in from right um
these people were were there um and
there was ambulances and police officers
and i don't know how they possibly could
have known that i was there maybe they
saw my my car on the side of the road
that's a possibility um but
where i was taking was uh was not a good
place you know it was a it was it was
this hospital that seemed to be like it
was
it was not your regular there was people
in there that were um
definitely a part i was gonna say yeah
the occult definitely goes into the
medical field the law enforcement all
that stuff you know a crazy thing that
um that happened to me
while i was there
and
they took out my blood
and what came out of my vein was water
and then the lady it's almost like they
looked at me and they laughed you know
kind of like oh wow look at that it's
like jesus is literally like taunting
the devil type thing you know so because
where i went to it wasn't a regular
facility it was it was a satanic
facility i believe
um and then from there i'll transfer to
another place and then they put me in a
a mental hospital type thing and then
they force fed me drugs
um and then after that i was taken out
um and i went through this whole entire
struggle for like three months of trying
to get off of the medication because it
was just terrible i wouldn't wish that
on my worst enemy you know the side
effects are really bad that's another
problem that i really have with uh
pharmacopoeia and all that um i am a
firm believer that a lot of those mental
diseases um they're incited by spirits
and demonic attacks you know
my cousin had a similar situation he was
in a place like that and he said they'd
put you on these drugs that make you go
crazy so he stopped he tried to stop
taking him he said when i stopped taking
it made me go even crazier because yeah
now you have these like
three what they call them
withdrawals and all this stuff and side
effects and everything and they're
terrible they're terrible to get off of
but i got saved by the grace of god i
ended up going to that baptist church
that i had had gone to
uh when i was a kid i had a prayer with
the pastor there
it was a very beautiful prayer very
spirit-filled prayer and i only went to
the hospital one more time after that
and um
and you know i i i stayed around there
with them for a while i started
recuperating getting better getting
closer to jesus again and you know those
thoughts started leaving me um
and and that presence started leaving me
and before i knew it you know i was
watching uh amazing facts again and
watching doug batchelor and i'll never
forget it um
i kneeled down and i i was i was in
torment because i really didn't want to
be on these medications i knew that
jesus did not want me to be on these
medications that he wanted me to uh be
in his spirit and that this was being
something that was blocking me from him
being able to use me fully
and and so i i
kneeled down and i asked god to deliver
me from it and every time i would get i
just
cold turkey now i wouldn't recommend
this for everybody um because the side
effects are really bad
and um but for me it was an extreme you
know and if
if you feel the spirit impressing you to
get rid of those medications then get
rid of it okay because jesus has
something better for you in your life he
wants to bring you his spirit and heal
you completely
and so i kneeled down and i had had
literally just every time i would get
the side effects i would kneel down and
i would pray and i was listening to doug
bashler and he said something have you
ever seen a mountain move right away
sometimes it may take a while for that
mountain to move but as soon as it moves
it's going to seem like it was in an
instant and that's exactly what happened
as soon as i was completely relieved
from that i went to the adventist church
and i decided to get baptized and from
there i started i had before that a
calling to be a pastor and they pointed
me in the right direction i ended up
hearing southern
well when the rest is history man
so
i'll just say
a lot of that sounds really crazy and
there's going to be people that are
going to
think that's i don't know whatever but
the thing is is this is all stuff we've
seen in the bible the dude that had
legions of demons in him who are saying
we are legion and
there's a woman who was cat you know
cast out seven spirits out of her name
or something
and so when they
you opened up a door by messing around
with the occult
eastern mysticism all these things
that allowed satan to
torment you in your mind and all these
things and put you through this whole
experience
but you are not too far gone for jesus
amen and he's got you to the point where
now you're
in your right mind and you're in school
and you're
have a passion to be a pastor like right
wow
regardless of what any critics say i
mean the fact that your life has changed
is the testimony itself that you are
down the right path i mean if satan
wanted to he could have had you go i
mean if you wanted to and he and he had
a grip in your life and you decided you
were going to go that way
you could have gone down the wrong path
yeah but it's true christ it's a
testimony for christ's power amen so how
long from the time you're baptized to
you wind up in school
um
a month later one month
in august i ended up coming here uh
august 17th and starting the salt
program so
last semester yeah saul program is an
amazing like in the fall semester yeah
last week were you in greek one with me
i was in greek one minute so you were
doing salt and greek
salt and greek wow wow so salt i went
through that that's a beautiful goal
winning
and leadership training four months of
intense evangelistic training and you're
out knocking on doors and getting bible
studies and learning
how to um you know address
whether like if somebody rebuttals and
stuff like that you
yeah you learn how to defend your faith
and i would recommend that every
christian take a program like the
assault program uh for me
i went into
i went to southern with a certain
perception on what it was going to be
like to be a pastor and after the salt
program my whole entire mind changed you
know i i i'm completely centered on
evangelism i want to bring people the
gospel so
what your testimony reminds me of is
this text in the book of acts so i'm
gonna read it yeah okay
so i i love this this
section here
it says but arise and this is 2026 uh
that's where i'm reading from acts 26
but rise and stand on your feet for i
have appeared to you for this purpose to
make you a minister and a witness both
of the things which you have seen and of
the things which i will reveal to you i
will deliver you from the jewish people
as well as from the gentiles to whom now
i send you to open their eyes in order
to turn them from darkness to light and
from the power of satan to god that they
may receive forgiveness of sins and
inheritance among those who are
sanctified by faith in me
wow
so
that's what god's in the business of
doing is transforming lives and taking
people from
you know a past where the enemy has a
grip on their life and freeing them
you know satan never wants to let
anybody free he always wants to keep
people captive yeah and god's in the
business of
you know delivering people and it sounds
like he delivered you in a very powerful
way
how exciting that now you get to be on
the front lines and
studying with people and you know
revealing truth to them and helping
preserve people for god's kingdom that's
awesome yeah best decision i ever made
uh also reminded me of isaiah 42 16 it
says i will
bring the blind by a way that they knew
not i will lead them in paths they have
not known i will make darkness light
before them and crooked things straight
these things will i do unto them and not
forsake them so you were on a path and
he said hey i got another path for you
and he made the the lightness dark and
he didn't forsake you through all that
it's from one extreme to the other
that's the way i see it you know rapper
to pastor to preacher
so
while we're wrapping up here
somebody's out there they're struggling
sorry
and
they're on that
teeter-totter they're having that
teeter-totter experience where it's like
you know the the call of the world is
here but then they've seen
some truth what do you say to that
person
seek jesus and
pray
make sure that you surround yourself
with the right type of people because if
you continue to surround yourself with
that worldly environment it's only going
to continue to influence you on that
path if you really want to seek truth
pray and god will take you there and
have faith believe in the fact that
jesus will take you to the truth and
then when you are presented with the
truth
really
take it into account for your life test
it yeah test the truth you will know
them by their fruits you shall know them
by their spirit and you'll be able to
see
the fact that in that worldly life
the fruits
aren't really all there
a lot of those fruits are rotten
and and a lot of the fruits that jesus
will bring to you will be
just that truth
um for me
my own struggle was realizing that god
was trying to take me to the right place
and then accepting the call the best
decision i have ever made in my life was
accepting the call to be a pastor
because had i never done that
my life would have never really taken a
turn for the better when i was a rapper
i was
aimless really you know i was just going
by i didn't know when when my big break
was going to come i didn't know what was
really going to happen in the next um
you know next year or a year and a half
i was just kind of idly walking by and
yeah i had some connections i made some
connections here but if you're in that
middle ground
it's kind of like
you're really not going to know which
way to go because you're you're in
between um accepting truth and then you
see this false here and and living the
lie can seem so appealing it could seem
so much fun it could seem like it's the
probably the greatest thing that will
ever happen in your life but then once
you really take that decision you
realize to yourself wow this wasn't even
worth it no you know
and um i would say
walk with the truth have trust in god
because even though um there's so many
misconceptions out there that uh might
tell you oh you know being a christian
is like oh now you have to give up all
fun or now you have to just be some
stiff all the time i'm not a stiff i
feel great as a christian and i have fun
all the time
and um and god wants to have you in a
good place
so that would be my advice
you guys have any last questions for
jose no i have one how did you come
across our youtube channel um a friend
uh called uh mickey he actually garcia
yeah
yeah he was one of the first people i
met too when i started coming to the
truth and he was uh he was a good
influence on me man yeah okay he was he
he introduced me to the ministry and
then because i would i would always talk
to them about the occult and then you
pointed me towards your ministry and i i
really enjoyed watching the ministry and
i really support what you guys are doing
here
it was a little thank you mickey for
that i know you're a supporter and yeah
also
shout out to the other guys in the class
if you're watching ryan raiden
and uh you know what
share this video with somebody who
may be on that teetering point in their
life it may not be an occult experience
it may not it may be something else
maybe it's a hollywood experience maybe
it's a artist experience who knows
share this with that person so that they
can see a testimony of how god changes a
life how god works in powerful ways and
how god can deliver anybody from
anywhere
so thank you guys for joining us on this
episode of led live we will see you next
time take care
[Music]
you